ADRIAN GRAHAM: Hi, and welcome
to Building a Virtual Post
Production Suite.
My name is Adrian
Graham, and I'm
a solutions architect for
Media and Entertainment
at Google Cloud.
Today, I want to talk about
content creation workflows
and how Google Cloud's
products can support
these types of workloads for
a creative workforce that
spans the world.
We're going to look at how
artists such as designers,
animators, or editors
can collaborate
across vast distances using a
solution that takes advantage
of Google's global
private fiber network
to reduce latency and improve
the overall user experience.
Content creation
is a global market.
And access to talent is
essential for finding
the right artist for the
job, even if they live
on the other side of the globe.
Companies who want
to take advantage
of regional
production tax credits
need to hire talent
in these locations.
But building a new physical
facility to house these artists
can be cost and
time prohibitive.
It doesn't make sense to build
a new facility in a new location
for every new production.
But on Google Cloud,
it's possible.
Today, I'm going to show you a
virtual post-production suite
that allows artists to work
with their favorite tools,
but with the added flexibility
and power of Google Cloud.
Consider the main components
of a virtual post-production
suite--
people such as artists,
producers, and engineers;
virtual workstations to
create and manage content;
shared storage so
users can collaborate;
compute clusters for
rendering or transcoding;
media asset management systems
and databases to keep track
of assets; and
archive and disaster
recovery to ensure durability
and to properly store data.
With a virtual
post-production suite,
all members of a
content creation team
can access the same assets
and resources regardless
of physical location.
Cloud native features such
as data encryption, identity
access management, and
multi-factor authentication
ensure high-value content
is secure and available only
to those granted access.
Google Cloud is authorized
by major Hollywood studios
to host tier-one content.
We work with international
security evaluators
and other third-party
auditors to ensure compliance
with security best practices,
local laws, and regulations.
To build a virtual
post-production suite on Google
Cloud, we need three things--
a client so artists can connect
from their local workstation,
laptop, or dedicated hardware
device, a broker that
authenticates users with
an identity service,
such as G Suite or
Active Directory.
Once authenticated,
the user traffic
is then routed to their
assigned resource.
The artist is then connected
to their workstation.
Here, artists can access common
resources such as shared file
systems, asset management
databases, archive workflows,
and other cloud-based
resources to automate
tasks such as
transcoding or rendering.
To connect to our
workstations, we're
going to use PC
over IP technology--
a remote display
protocol from Teradici
PC over IP technology empowers
artists, editors, and engineers
to display lossless, high
resolution, high frame rate
images and video across
multiple monitors
on a variety of
endpoint devices,
from laptops to highly secure
stateless PC over IP Zero
Clients.
Using Teradici Cloud
Access software,
which is built on this
PC over IP technology,
I can connect to a workstation
running in the Los Angeles
region.
Once authenticated, I'm logged
into my virtual workstation
running Windows 2019 server
with Windows desktop experience.
This is an NVIDIA Quadro
virtual workstation
using an NVIDIA
P4 GPU, as well as
Teradici Cloud Access software.
On my workstation, I can
open an existing project
in Adobe Premiere Pro.
According to
GCPing.com, my latency
to this workstation
in the LA region
is only around 20 milliseconds.
So the experience feels
like a local workstation.
Audio is synchronized properly,
and I can scrub the timeline
without lag or delay.
I'm going to upload some footage
from my local workstation
to the cloud volume.
To do this, I'm using
IBM Aspera on cloud.
Once uploaded, I can move this
footage into my cloud volume.
I could also use other
industry-standard file transfer
tools, such as Signiant
or even Drive File Stream
for ingesting footage.
I'm going to add this
footage to my edit
and drop it into the timeline.
Then I'm going to
pass the modified
project over to another editor.
Let's bring in my
colleague, [? Marku, ?]
a solutions architect
who is based in Tokyo.
He's going to make
some additional changes
to this edit, then send it
back to me for rendering.
[? MARKU: ?] Hey, thanks, Adrian
OK, on my cloud workstation,
I can see the edits
that you made.
I can see the exact
same project data
because we are using the
NetApp Global File Cache.
And when I opened the
shared Premiere Pro
Project, any assets
or files that changed
will be read across
Google's network
and cached locally
to the Tokyo region.
I'm going to add my own
footage from the game using
the same technique
that Adrian did.
And once this
footage is available,
I will add it to the edit.
I saved my changes
to the team project.
And now, Adrian, you
should get a notification.
ADRIAN GRAHAM:
Thanks, [? Marku. ?]
I see those changes almost
immediately on my workstation.
And the footage you uploaded
is coming across now.
[? MARKU: ?] All
right, thanks, Adrian.
See you later.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: I
could render this edit
on my virtual workstation on a
separate server running Adobe
Media Encoder or using any
one of our partner transcoding
solutions on Google Cloud.
For this project, I'm rendering
the video on another instance.
When the render is done,
I can view the result
on my virtual workstation
and play back the videos
I generated at full resolution.
This is a relatively
simple example
of a virtual
post-production suite.
We didn't cover asset ingestion
or archive and disaster
recovery.
We also didn't explore how
intelligent content discovery
can help content creators
understand, organize,
and monetize their
assets on Google Cloud.
This demo showed you connecting
to and performing editing tasks
on a cloud workstation,
uploading footage
from a local workstation
for use in my edit,
collaboration with others
sharing my project anywhere
in the world, and how data
can be securely synchronized
across Google Cloud regions.
There's a lot of new
and exciting projects
we're working on to take
media and entertainment
workloads to the next level.
Check the documentation to learn
more, and thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]